more emergency aid for small businesses
another huge spike in unemployment
claims and raising the specter of states
going bankrupt those are just some of
the economic issues that are making
headlines this week here to talk about
that and more is CBS News senior
business analyst Jill Schlesinger Jill
let's start with the unemployment right
now twelve million Americans are
receiving unemployment benefits it's a
record number more than twice the worst
that we saw back in 2009 so with that in
mind what does the job outlook in the
economic outlook going forward well
let's look at the broader economic
output we are already in a recession
we'll get our first numbers that show
that probably in on Wednesday from the
government but it's the second quarter
those numbers won't be reported for a
month or two and that's going to be
devastating we could see a decline of
about 15 to 20 percent from last year a
quarter over quarter as well a big
decline and as you mentioned all these
workers they're currently receiving
unemployment benefits the question is
when things do start to open up what
will their job prospects be you know
what the worst part of the recession
Dana we knew that there were about six
and-a-half unemployed job seekers for
every single position that was open that
dropped to below one just in February
and a lot of economists that I speak to
are worried that that competition for
the jobs that are going to be shrinking
in the next month it's going to push
down wages so we're very concerned about
what that intermediate term outlook is
meaning through the end of this year for
many US workers yeah even if you do get
the job who knows what that salary will
be if it can be comparable and speaking
of the businesses and small businesses
specifically there were a lot that were
shut out of those first rounds of PPP
loans big businesses got them instead
sort of a two-fold question how did that
happen where we saw bigger businesses
getting them and in this second round
will the small businesses now be taken
care of well the reason it happened is
that the banks were really ill-equipped
to set up this loan facility so quickly
and so they naturally went to the
clients with whom they had a
preexisting relationship many of those
clients were big businesses we should
also note that if you're a big business
you probably have a chief financial
officer or a controller who's going to
be on top of that process and really be
able to access the bank's funds quickly
now whether or not we get smaller
businesses involved in this next phase
is questionable I'm hearing that the
backlog of folks who have already been
approved means that this new round of
funding about 320 billion more into the
program could be exhausted within days
the first round that was exhausted
within two weeks and this is incredibly
important because a lot of these small
businesses they will simply fail without
a lifeline jill some american workers
will actually earn more money by
claiming these enhanced unemployment
benefits so what makes the most sense
for the job market right now it is such
a hard decision if I'm a worker and I
can earn say 14 15 bucks an hour going
back on my boss's payroll but I'm
earning more than that as I sit home
safely with my family why would I go
back onto the payrolls now that said
what's really going to be interesting is
what will happen in a few months because
frankly if you make the decision not to
go back to work and collect your
unemployment you don't know what the job
market is going to be in four or five
months so there is a risk in doing that
of course I understand it a lot of
economists that I speak to say what they
would have rather seen instead of the
PPP program a program putting more money
directly into workers pockets for a
longer period of time maybe $1,200
checks for a few months in a row so we
don't have that this is what we have
Jeff and it's a really hard situation it
certainly is alright Jill thank you very
much